women need to raise the family right but
but you also need men so we like we've
seen what happens when fathers aren't in
the home so men and women are equally I
think needed in the family but when it
comes to running a society most of the
jobs that run the infrastructure of
society so like the policemen the power
lines the K like all the things women's
jobs could go away tomorrow society
would still run because you know what
what women are construction workers if
women are in construction they're like
in management or some job that
we don't really need let's just be
honest
where men are the ones doing the hard
like the hard jobs the street sweepers
the sewage like all the stuff that like
if went out tomorrow society would not
run